[Music]
so who does she marry no one she doesn't
marry either of them
no
no no no that won't work at all well she
says the whole book that she doesn't
want to marry who cares
girls want to see women married not
consistent no it isn't the right ending
the right ending is the one that sells
hey there it's naz and welcome to an
incredible new episode of rt essentials
what makes it incredible well the films
we are discussing of course but more
specifically the writers behind these
films yes everyone remembers the tom
cruises and most people remember the
james camerons but more often than not
the writers are the unsung heroes the
true visionaries i mean after all a film
is only as good as its script here's a
little test can you name the
screenwriters that penned your top five
favorite films it's not easy is it and
here's an even more revealing question
of those five screenwriters how many are
women according to an article in variety
women make up only 17 of all working
screenwriters in 2021 and before emerald
finnell script won in 2021 for promising
young woman a woman hadn't taken home
the best original screenplay oscar since
diablo cody who won for juno back in
2007 which honestly feels like ages ago
i mean it kinda was women have been
underrepresented in hollywood since the
beginning especially when it comes to
screenwriting but one thing is for sure
there is no shortage of female-driven
brilliance at our viewing disposal so
without further ado i present to you our
selections for incredible movies written
by women
metropolis
starting with the 1927 silent classic
metropolis written by theovon harbour
and based on her novel of the same name
published two years prior the film is
set in the future and presents a
beautiful utopian society existing above
a bleak underworld populated by
mistreated workers one youthful member
of the privileged class named freder
discovers the grim scene under the city
and enlists the help of a rebellious
teacher named maria to unite the workers
and overcome the expansive class divide
however this proves to be difficult
because freder's authoritative father
happens to be the utopian city's master
and doesn't exactly align with his son's
vision metropolis featured
groundbreaking special effects and set
designs with the cityscape inspired by
director fritz lang's first visit to new
york in the 1920s
lang is also considered a pioneer of the
science fiction genre and though
metropolis isn't technically the first
sci-fi film it's certainly one of the
most innovative and one of the earliest
displays of that genre's limitless
potential in cinema but let's not forget
the true visionary behind metropolis
harbour who was also lang's creative
partner and wife at the time harvoo had
already established herself as a
prolific writer in germany publishing
her first novel in 1910 at the age of
only 22. she would go on to receive
universal recognition for her novels and
additionally for her contributions to
film not only writing several other
successful movies with lang but also
pending scripts for directors fw morneau
carl dreyer and e.a dupont in time
metropolis has received critical praise
with roger ebert calling it one of the
great achievements of the silent era a
work so audacious in its vision and so
angry in its message that it is if
anything more powerful today than when
it was made and honestly we couldn't
agree more
halloween
[Music]
this next feature births one of the most
feared and mythologized antagonists ever
michael myers and no we're not talking
about the guy in austin powers we are
talking about the villain in halloween
written by deborah hill this indie
slasher was released in 1978 and
directed by none other than john
carpenter who also co-wrote the script
with hill the movie follows our favorite
masked maniac as he escapes the
sanitarium and returns to his hometown
of haddonfield illinois where he sucks a
young babysitter named laurie strode
played by jamie lee curtis hill's career
in the biz began in 1975 where she
worked as a production assistant on
documentaries she quickly worked her way
up to the job of scripps supervisor
where she first met carpenter assisting
on his 1976 film assault on precinct 13.
only a couple years later hill and
carpenter would co-write halloween a
movie made on a shoestring budget of
just over 300 000 that went on to gross
over 70 million
[Music]
[Applause]
hill's creative journey was nothing
short of meteoric and her professional
relationship with carpenter would last
decades spawning two halloween sequels
and the films the fog escape from new
york and escape from la the script for
halloween took 10 days to write with
hill crafting most of the females
characters dialogues using her
experience working as a babysitter
during her teenage years as inspiration
though the film received mixed reviews
upon release it has since been
recognized as one of the greatest and
most influential horror films ever made
and has been selected for preservation
in the us national film registry by the
library of congress by the way there are
now a total of 12 halloween films in the
franchise but it's pretty hard to top
the hill carpenter duo that brought us
the first three
e.t the
it's too extraterrestrial
love to walk from here
[Music]
screenwriter melissa madison lived an
extraordinary life she was family
friends with the coppolas and got to
work on the godfather part two she
married harrison ford this same year
return of the jedi came out and even
developed a lasting friendship with the
dalai lama one that blossomed while she
was working on the script for kundan but
what mathison is perhaps best known for
is writing the screenplay for e.t the
extraterrestrial now even if you are an
extraterrestrial there's a good chance
you're familiar with this film its
characters and their journey but just in
case you aren't it is a story of a kind
alien dubbed e.t that becomes stranded
on earth and is discovered by a young
boy named elliot elliot and his siblings
decide to keep et's existence a secret
but when the gentle little alien falls
ill elliott is put in a dire situation
and soon the government intervenes which
is usually not a good thing in films
like this just saying my god he's
talking
[Music]
director steven spielberg had been
working on the concept for night skies a
film about malicious aliens that
terrorize a family but the idea didn't
come to fruition after spielberg relayed
his concept for night skies to matheson
she came back after eight weeks with the
first draft of a script entitled e.t and
me spielberg considered her first draft
to be perfect which if you know anything
about spielberg he doesn't take the
ideas of perfection lightly et was
released in june of 1982 and became the
highest grossing film of all time
surpassing star wars i mean sorry han
solo madison got you there critics also
praised the classic with the guardian
writing that quote e.t is superlative
piece of popular cinema a dream of
childhood brilliantly orchestrated to
involve not only children but anyone
able to remember being one and so much
of this film's success can be attributed
to mathis's heartfelt ingenious writing
lost in translation
you want a whiskey
this is not whiskey this is iced tea if
you gave me a real whiskey
i need mysterious face attention is
mysterious mysterious i i think i know
what you want you want this right
i need more mysterious and uh more
mysterious yeah i'll just try to think
where the hell is the whiskey speaking
of the coppola's lost in translation was
written and directed by sophia the
youngest child and only daughter of
filmmakers eleanor and francis ford
coppola sophia is as close to royalty as
you can get in hollywood but that
doesn't mean she didn't tirelessly work
to carve her own path and craft a
powerful and original voice in 1999
while still in her 20s coppola premiered
her featured directorial debut the
virgin suicides which received critical
praise and cemented her as a filmmaking
force to be reckoned with just over four
years later she released lost in
translation and this is where things got
crazy this movie became a phenomenon
grossing over 118 million against a
budget of just 4 million it's the story
of an aging movie star named bob harris
played by bill murray who chance meets a
conflicted newlywed named charlotte in
tokyo bob is there shooting a japanese
whiskey commercial and charlotte is
there to accompany her celebrity
photographer husband the two connect to
strangers in a foreign land and soon
they form an unlikely but heartfelt bond
as they explore the city and find solace
in each other's company does it get
easier
no
yes
it gets easier
oh yeah
look at you
thanks
coppola described the film as a story
about quote things being disconnected
and looking for moments of connection
and she based the plot and themes on her
own experiences traveling to tokyo in
her early 20s the writer director was
set on casting murray for the lead and
infamously pursued him for months
sending letters and leaving countless
voicemails he finally accepted and soon
coppola cast scarlett johansson as
co-star charlotte after liking her
performance in manny and lo murray and
johansson made for an odd but somehow
magnetic on-screen duo and their
chemistry was instrumental to the film's
success critics unanimously praised lost
in translation with newsweek pointing
out that quote with this film it becomes
clear that sofia coppola is a filmmaker
with eyes all her own coppola also took
home the oscar for best original
screenplay
pariah
you're not going to church in that
what's wrong with this where's that
blouse i bought you what's wrong with
this
dad
do what your mom says are you hungry
here let me heat this up for you that's
okay i'll take some more just leave it
me leave me out of it now go get changed
dad what's wrong with this outfit
nothing see i'm not gonna argue with you
do what she says priya is a 2011 drama
written and directed by d reese and
starring otapera odier kim wayans and
asha davis it's a story of a lesbian
teenager named ali k who lives in
brooklyn's fort greene neighborhood and
quietly embraces her identity while
looking for her first lover when ali k's
mother pressures her to befriend her
colleague's daughter beena ali kay is
pleasantly surprised and the two form a
genuine companionship rhys attended nyu
for film where she had spike lee as a
professor and mentor which is honestly
about as cool as it gets i was going to
say too cool for school but clearly that
is not the case reece then went on to
work under lee on the film's inside man
and when the levees broke it was during
this period that she began writing the
script for what would become pariah and
for her graduate thesis she directed a
short film based on the first act of
this screenplay i mean i haven't even
wore this you could rock that
if you want
but i understand if you got better
things to do
no i'm down
i don't want you getting all him done no
seriously
i'm down for whatever
real
promise
the short was a success and received
numerous accolades including the
audience award at the los angeles film
festival years later rhys expanded the
semi-autobiographical short film into
the feature-length version with spike
lee serving as one of the executive
producers pariah premiered at sundance
in january of 2011 and received the
excellence and cinematography award
additionally critics were overwhelmingly
positive with the new york times writing
that the film quote has a point to make
and a point of view to argue but it also
above all wants to illuminate an
individual universe of meaning and
emotion the online magazine auto
straddle also placed paria third on its
list of the top 200 lesbian queer and
bisexual movies of all time and wrote
that quote the acting and directing
create a winning combination for
unlocking the most powerful tool in
social change empathy
the diary of a teenage girl
what you girls
may not understand about your mother is
she is and has always been
incapable of taking responsibility for
our own life don't talk about a mom like
that please yeah pascal don't talk about
her dad it's dad and okay fine just stop
with the inquisition next up we have the
diary of a teenage girl a dramedy
written and directed by marielle heller
and based on the graphic novel of the
same name by phoebe glockner it stars
belle paoli alexander skarsgard
christopher maloney and kristen wiig and
was released in the united states in
august of 2015. the film is set in san
francisco during the 70s and tells the
story of a clever 15 year old named
minnie who embarks on an enthusiastic
sexual odyssey kicking off with her
mother's current lover monroe in an
interview with deadline heller spoke of
her collaboration with glockner and
their mutual respect for each other as
artists heller explained that from the
beginning glockner had a lot of trust
and understood what heller needed in
order to make this movie i've decided
aileen kaminsky is my favorite
cartoonist
she must be beautiful and work all the
time at a little drawing table with
arkham nearby his drawing table and they
discuss their drawings and their pens
i imagine they're happy
i wish i knew someone who was happy
heller added that she had to take
glockner's novel and let it become its
own artistic project and its own
separate entity and that's exactly what
she did but before the film was ever in
development heller had actually adapted
glockner's novel into a play where she
played the lead role the play ran for
six weeks and was critically acclaimed
and ultimately helped convince glockner
to give heller the film rights so let's
just recap heller wrote and starred in a
successful play that she then developed
into a successful movie which she wrote
and directed i mean is there anything
that she can't do she also starred in
the queen's gambit the diary of a
teenage girl was widely praised by
audiences and critics with indie wire
calling it shocking but genuine poignant
and hilarious and vox adding that it's
quietly radical and is a story of huge
emotions and big moments told via
intimate gestures and tiny power shifts
the writer iris asked you to take care
of gus on his travels lord just be with
him all the time and protect him keep
him safe god
jesus in my prayer
the writer is a modern western written
and directed by chloe zhao and released
in april of 2018. the film centers
around the lakota sioux tribe of the
pine ridge reservation in south dakota
and specifically follows a young cowboy
named brady who suffers brain damage
from a rodeo accident brady's injury is
left him with a metal plate in his head
and his doctors have ordered him to
never return to the saddle because any
further damage would likely be fatal as
brady digests this news and his altered
way of life he finds himself wandering
the reservation struggling to find a new
purpose xiao rose to prominence in 2015
with the success of her first feature
film songs my brother taught me which
earned her nominations for best verse
feature and the someone to watch award
at the independent spirit awards
i know you're turning away from your
buddies and i know you don't want to do
that
boy
zhao also set songs my brothers taught
me at the pine ridge reservation and her
time there helped to inspire the
screenplay and somewhat true story that
would eventually become the writer in
fact part of what gave the writer an
unparalleled authenticity was zhao's
decision to cast real people playing
themselves the protagonist brady is
inspired by and played by brady and the
same goes for brady's family this was a
bold choice on xiao's part and
unprecedented in cinema the writer was a
small commercial success but received
universal acclaim with many highlighting
zhao's direction and the raw
performances from the untrained cast the
chicago reader called it an
extraordinary translation of life into
art and sight and sound wrote that it
reshapes the traditional cowboy
narrative in a way that both embraces
and challenges western tropes in 2021
zhao won the best picture and best
director oscars for her film nomad land
making her the first asian woman and
only the second woman ever to win best
director at the oscars some
well-deserved history making right there
the farewell
foreign
next up we have the farewell a dramedy
written and directed by lulu wang and
starring aquafina the film was released
in july of 2019 and follows billy and
her family as they return to china under
the guise of a fake wedding all to say
goodbye to their beloved matriarch who
is unaware that she only has a few weeks
to live yes just to clarify the family
is aware of their grandmother's
prognosis but chooses just not to tell
her it sounds bizarre to some but not to
wang because the farewell is
autobiographical and the same exact
situation played out with her own
grandmother in an interview with slate
wang stated that she had been driven by
how conflicted she was between the value
system and what she felt was very wrong
the lying to her grandmother part of
course
wow
wang even admitted that her real-life
grandmother would come to visit the set
during filmmaking and wang would have to
tell everyone not to expose the film's
plot to her which is honestly equal part
hilarious and equal part terrifying i
mean imagine if you're the poor soul who
accidentally reveals to wang's
grandmother that the entire film is
based around her dying and nobody
telling her about it yikes the farewell
was a commercial and critical success
grossing over 23 million at the box
office and receiving the impressive four
out of four stars from roger ebert.com
additionally the independent uk called
it a comedy of warmth and racing honesty
and added that simply put it's one of
the best films of the year
little women do you love it
if he asked me again i think i would say
yes
you think he'll ask me again
but do you love him
i care more to be loved
i want to be loved
that is not the same as loving there are
two kinds of people in this world those
who firmly believe greta gerwig deserve
the best director oscar nomination for
little women and those who have never
actually seen greta gerwig's little
women there's just no middle ground
because anyone who has seen this film
would agree that it is a timeless
masterpiece much like alcott's novel
itself the ensemble cast includes sercia
ronan emma watson florence pugh eliza
scanlin laura dern timothy chalamet and
meryl streep i mean come on too much
talent for one film i shouldn't even
mention that alexandre desplat did the
score because now we're just rubbing it
in little women was released in december
of 2019 and grossed over 218 million
against a budget of 40 million making
this gerwig's most commercially
successful film to date and only her
second don't marry him
why
why
you know why
no
no
yes no glory
what you're being mean stop it stop it
i have been second to jo my whole life
in everything
and i will not be the person you settle
for just because you cannot have her i
won't i won't do it 2017's lady bird was
gerwig's solo directorial debut and
garnered five oscar nominations
including one for best picture not to be
totally outdone but little women earned
six oscar nominations best picture she's
two for two with that one best actress
best supporting actress best adapted
screenplay best original score and best
costume design but despite all of that
no nomination for best director
british columnist alison pearson of the
telegraph labeled this occurrence a
whole new standard of idiocy and further
wrote that it belittles women's
experiences the la times concluded that
this snub was due to a general
psychological tendency to unwittingly
view women's work as less creative than
men's it goes without saying but people
were pretty up in arms about this snub
or not this doesn't take away from the
fact that writer director gerway created
a beautiful adaptation one that managed
to breathe new life into a story that
has been told countless times the new
yorker wrote that it may just be the
best film yet made by an american woman
and the associated press deemed gurwig's
direction an astonishing accomplishment
portrait of a lady on fire
is
last but not least is portrait of a lady
on fire a french romance drama written
and directed by celine shiyama the film
stars noemi milan and adele now and is
set in france at the end of the 18th
century it's a story of an artist named
marianne who is commissioned by a
powerful family to paint a wedding
portrait for their daughter eloise
as the painting commences marianne and
eloise develop a mutual attraction and a
passionate love affair ensues chiama's
work is known for its themes of gender
fluidity and sexual identity and the
brilliant director writer has been
crafting her singular voice since the
release of her first feature water
lilies back in 2007
for a portrait of a lady on fire shiyama
chose this particular moment in art
history because she wanted to draw
attention to the hundreds of women
painters at the time who had flourishing
careers and have been largely left out
of the narrative film critic rachel
seamy of the new yorker poignantly wrote
that the film examines quote the
entanglements between artistic creation
and burgeoning love between memory and
ambition and freedom the film is about
the erotic electric connection between
women when they find their desire for
creative experience fulfilled in each
other but it is equally about the powers
of art to validate preserve and console
after a romance is over i mean that's
powerful that was really deep and that's
a perfect place to wrap up our list of
incredible movies written by women as is
always the case we couldn't include
every title that fits the bill there are
far too many incredible movies written
by incredible women but don't fret we
have plenty of rt essential episodes
coming your way so i'm sure we'll get
there soon thanks again for tuning in i
am naz perez and to all you aspiring
screenwriters out there remember these
five magic words maximum impact with
minimum space
[Music]
[Music]
you